hey guys so I'm always getting tons of
questions and comments and video
responses about computers but I got this
one in particular that I thought might
need to be addressed just my family
computers so he decided to send me a
professional PC Justine to help out
Harold this is ridiculous
we need new computers right now this
minute no Martha I just don't know what
to get Oh mother and father why can't
somebody help us with these problems
that we are having hello family units
I'm PC Justin I'm gonna be here to guide
you with your computer purchasing
process we just don't know what to buy
it's simple dad person how do you use a
computer on a daily basis well I need a
big screen so I can play computer games
and I also need to make videos about me
playing those computer games it sounds
like you need and desktop with a fast
processor and a lot of storage you can
also customize the monitor and connect
on your video and gaming peripherals
does this keyboard have the letter J on
it yes it has all of the letters of the
alphabet I use a lot of J's um Pearson
hey we're talking about me yes I am so I
assume that you would want something to
allow you to chat online with your
friends watch movies yet be able to
handle all of your school projects and
documents yes a young preteen like me
does all of those things then you should
get a laptop it weighs less than a
school book has a DVD player and it's
energy efficient so people go on and on
as you go on and on
that lady uses a lot of big words and
tell about you your wife mother what do
you use a computer for I'm too busy
running my lady errands and shopping for
bargains and working my bones to the
bone as a bone doctor I don't have time
to keep up with the rest of the world
then I recommend the netbook it's
affordable they just lie on this
connectivity and it's small enough to be
completely portable
oh thank you oh thank you thank you
my work here isn't it you solved our
computer problems
you saved my marriage you stole my
turkey sandwich how do we use these
things Wow so I'm so glad PC Justine
could help that family off now I want to
know from you guys leave a comment or
make a video response and tell me some
computer buying tips or some crazy
stories that you've had while trying to
buy a computer I'll be choosing three of
you guys at random to win a new computer
this contest will end on January 1st so
feel free to make a video response and
leave a comment every single day and
I'll see you guys then No okay I look
forward to seeing your sponsors